Cernik dogs can give people who are
physically or emotionally impaired
invaluable help but many people use
untrained pets to receive privileges
they are not entitled to new laws make
it illegal to misrepresent a service dog
and some of those laws come with the
threat of jail time Don Dahler shows us
how imposters can hurt the image of
service animals a snowboarding accident
in 2007 put Christina Slavin in a
wheelchair but it didn't take her off
the mountain I knew it was not
necessarily a life-altering injury it
was just a change
let's do later when she's not giving ski
lessons to people with disabilities
you'll find her accompanied by her
faithful lab and service dog Earle does
a lot of retrieving for me when I lose
my phone he's actually very good about
finding I could use him like these
puppies smothering our camera Earl was
trained at needs a service dog industry
leader for more than 40 years jerry
Deroche is need CEO how many tasks do
these dogs have to learn we train the
dogs in about 50 different tasks can be
trained to open doors to turn on lights
to retrieve objects that's the major
difference between trained service dogs
and the many imposters gaining access to
the places that accommodate the disabled
you may have seen the cute chihuahua or
even occasional pig posing is something
more than the well-intentioned pet that
they are do you think that fake service
dogs can hurt the public's impression of
real service dogs I know that big
service dogs hurt the public perception
of real service dogs because I see it
every day there's people that have been
bitten in stores dogs have had you know
accidents and stores or just been
generally disruptive just trading a
service dog to be an invaluable and
well-heeled companion is difficult but
getting fake credentials to pretend your
pet is qualified couldn't be easier
within 24 hours of logging onto one
website we obtained a phony certificate
an ID
for my border collie Abbi three days
later her uniform arrived and without my
having to show any proof of a disability
so what would you say to someone who is
either doing this or thinking about
doing this I would say that I
understands people people's desire to
have their dog with them and they don't
think it's a big deal just as people
park in handicapped spots and they think
it's not a big deal
a newly proposed law in Massachusetts
would make misrepresenting a service
animal illegal if passed Massachusetts
would join twelve other states where
it's already law the toughest of which
is in California where the maximum
penalty is a $1,000 fine and up to six
months in jail
can you imagine what your life would be
like without him he makes my life worth
living every single day for CBS this
morning Don Dahler Princeton
Massachusetts I like that look at the
banner fall pause oh yeah